ah mais le mec est complètement skizo en
fait arrête de traiter les gens de skizo
d'abord parce que c'est psychophobe je
t'en ai parlé dans la partie 1 et
ensuite parce que ça veut pas du tout
dire ce que tu crois un schizo un
schizophrène c'est pas du tout quelqu'un
qui a plusieurs personnalités ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle un trouble dissociatif
de l'identité avant on disait trouble de
personnalités multiples ça n'a rien à
voir avec la schizophrénie la
schizophrénie c'est une maladie
psychiatrique dans laquelle il y a une
perte de contact avec la réalité il y a
des hallucinations des idées délirantes
il y a aussi un isolement social avec
une forme de dépression il y a des
perturbations de la pensée de la parole
des émotion mais pas de personnalités
multiple et dans tous les cas rien qui
mérite que sa maladie devienne une
insulte parce que aucune maladie devrait
être une insulte si tu veux vraiment
insulter quelqu'un insulte-le pour ce
qu' a fait de mal insulte pas des
personnes qui souffrent et qui ont rien
demandé